dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife
between 2013 and 2015 deepmind
worked on an incredible learning
algorithm by the name
deep reinforcement learning this
technique looked at the pixels of the
game
was given a controller and played much
like a human would
with the exception that it learned to
play some atari games
on a superhuman level i have tried to
train it a few years ago
and would like to invite you for a
marvelous journey
to see what happened when it starts
learning to play an
old game atari breakout at first the
algorithm loses all of its lives
without any signs of intelligent action
if we wait a bit it becomes better at
playing the game
roughly matching the skill level of an
adapt player
but here's the catch if we wait for
longer
we get something absolutely spectacular
over time it learns to play like a pro
and finds out that the best way to win
the game
is digging a tunnel through the bricks
and hid them from behind
this technique is a combination of a
neural network that processes the visual
data
that we see on the screen and a
reinforcement learner
that comes up with the gameplay related
decisions
this is an amazing algorithm a true
breakthrough
in ai research a key point in this work
was that the problem formulation here
enabled us to measure
our progress easily we hit one break we
get some points
so do a lot of that lose a few lives
the game ends so don't do that
easy enough but there are other
exploration based games like montezuma's
revenge
or pitfall that it was not good at and
man these games are a nightmare for any
ai
because there is no score or at the very
least
it's hard to define how well we are
doing because there are no scores it is
hard to motivate an
ai to do anything at all other than just
wander around
aimlessly if no one tells us if we are
doing well or not
which way do we go explore this space
or go to the next one how do we solve
all this and with that let's discuss the
state of play in ais playing
difficult exploration-based computer
games
and i think you will love to see how far
we have come
since first there is a previous line of
work that
infused these agents with a very
human-like property
curiosity that agent was able to do
much much better at these games and then
got addicted to the tv but that's a
different story
note that the tv problem has been
remedied since
and this new method attempts to solve
hard exploration games
by watching youtube videos of humans
playing the game
and learning from that as you see it
just rips through these levels in
montezuma's revenge
and other games too so i wonder
how does all this magic happen how did
this agent learn to explore
well it has three things going for it
that really makes this work
one the skeptical scholar would say that
all this takes
is just copy pasting what it saw from
the human player
also imitation learning is not new which
is a point that we will address in a
moment
so why bother with this now
hold on to your papers and observe as it
seems
noticeably less efficient than the human
teacher was
until we realized that this is not the
human player
and this is not the ai but the other way
around
look it was so observant and took away
so much from the human demonstrations
that in the end
it became even more efficient than its
human teacher
whoa absolutely amazing
and while we are here i would like to
dissect this copy-paste argument
you see it has an understanding of the
game and does not just copy the human
demonstrator
but even if it just copied what it saw
it would not be so easy because the ai
only sees
images and it has to translate how the
images change
in response to us pressing buttons on
the controller
we might also encounter the same level
but
at a different time and we have to
understand how to vanquish an opponent
and how to perform that two nobody
hooked the agent into the game
information
which is huge this means that it doesn't
know what buttons are pressed on the
controller
no internal numbers or game states are
given to it
and most importantly it is also not
given
the score of the game we discussed how
difficult this makes
everything unfortunately this means that
there is no easy way out
it really has to understand what it sees
and mine
out the relevant information from each
of these videos
and as you see it does that with flying
colors
loving it and three it can handle the
domain gap
previous imitation learning methods did
not deal with that too well
so what does that mean let's look at
this latent space together
and find out this is what a latent space
looks like if we just
embed the pixels that we see in the
videos
don't worry i'll tell you in a moment
what that is here the clusters are
nicely clumped up
away from each other so that's probably
good
right well in this problem not so much
the latent space means a place where
similar kinds of data
are meant to be close to each other
these are snippets of the demonstration
videos that the clusters relate to
let's test that together do you think
these images
are similar yes
most of us humans would say that these
are quite similar
in fact they are nearly the same so
is this a good latent space embedding
no not in the slightest this data is
similar
therefore these should be close to each
other but this previous technique did
not recognize that
because these images have slightly
different colors
aspect ratios this has a text overlay
but we all understand that despite all
that we are looking
at the same game through different
windows
so does the new technique recognize that
oh yes beautiful praise the papers
similar game states are now close to
each other
we can align them properly and therefore
we can learn
more easily from them this is one of the
reasons why it can play so well
so there you go these new ai agents can
look
at how we perform complex exploration
games
and learn so well from us that in the
end
they do even better than we do and now
to get them to write some amazing papers
for us
or you know two minute papers episodes
what a time to be alive this episode has
been supported
by weights and biases in this post they
show you
how to use their tool to check and
visualize what your neural network is
learning
and even more importantly a case study
on how to find bugs in your system
and fix them weights and biases provides
tools to track your experiments
in your deep learning projects their
system is designed to save you a ton of
time
and money and it is actively used in
projects at prestigious labs
such as open ai toyota research github
and more and the best part is that
weights and biases is free for all
individuals academics and open source
projects
it really is as good as it gets make
sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or just click the link in the
video description
and you can get a free demo today our
thanks to weights and biases for their
long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time